Oh Sophie Oh see
whoa the world here we're gonna blow up
the world
sounds good right this is the fourth day
of bang a week hope you enjoyed it so
far we are well I am I'd have to clear
up all this so I'm not doing it Dan's
not enjoying this one right so let's
think I might blow up the world though
sueschubert scared of the world right
pesky earth oh Jesus
I was awesome
should we further back the mental
records gonna blow up idiot oh that was
unbelievable
you let get in tight with the camera
angle yes I get it I got soaked wolves
don't go out downwards and went up
where's a tide away oh that the class is
right inside so ah thank Christ
yeah well luckily well we were to find
North America pretty much intact
actually yeah that's my house and uh we
found England there's your house but
we've lost Scotland and Ireland
unfortunately the United Kingdom has
been severed a shame shame but at least
we've got Wales I think new casters do
that unfortunately no note has got the
color cuts off around Leeds if you're in
Leeds you made it yeah well done all
right
shooting tomorrow for the big finale Oh
boom we can finally figure out all that
bloody hoop is doing on the back of the
tree I might be able to guess to be here
but and the fact I'm covered in
something over yeah but don't mistake
that not this that is something dinner
follow us on Twitter Gavin free Daniel
Gruchy and check back tomorrow yeah
we'll see